[Música]
en el mundo de jrr gandalf es uno de los
cinco Brujos enviado por baylor para
guiar a los habitantes de la tierra
media en sus batallas contra las fuerzas
del mal de sauron el cuerpo de gandalf
era mortal sujeto a las leyes físicas de
la tierra media pero su espíritu era
inmortal como se ve cuando muere como
gandalf el gris y resucita como
gandalfel blanco según el guión de
huachowski un humano libre solo tiene
que conectarse y violar el código
binario neón de Matrix para aprender a
volar un helicóptero en apenas unos
segundos y si eres El Elegido o uno de
los elegidos ni siquiera necesitas un
helicóptero solo un par de gafas
geniales los gatos Chester pueden hacer
malabarismos con sus cabezas los ipads
son rudimentarios ningún juego de
quidditch se termina hasta que las nets
dorada es atrapada y la respuesta a la
más importante de la vida del universo y
a todo ciertamente es 42 así como en la
vida real los personajes de ficción
operan de forma uniforme dentro de un
espectro de leyes físicas y sociales es
lo que hace que estos mundos complejos
sean creíbles comprensibles y que valgan
la pena explorar en la vida real la ley
de la gravedad mantiene los siete libros
de la serie de Harry Potter en su sitio
en millones de estantes alrededor del
mundo sabemos que esto es verdad Pero
también sabemos que desde que jk
escribió las palabras brujo varita
mágica y wingardium leviosa esa ley de
la gravedad dejó de existir en los
billones de páginas que descansan en
esos sujetalibros
los autores de obras de ciencia ficción
y fantasía crean literalmente mundos
crean leyes mapas linajes lenguas
culturas universos universos
alternativos dentro de universos y de
esos mundos surgen historias historias y
más historias cuando están bien creados
los lectores pueden comprender los
mundos de ficción y sus leyes también
como los personajes que viven en ellos y
a veces también o incluso mejor que lo
que El lector puede comprender el mundo
externo fuera del libro
Pero cómo cómo los garabatos humanos
plasmados en una página pueden entrar
por nuestros ojos y mandarles señales a
nuestro cerebros de modo que
decodificamos lógica y emocionalmente
como narraciones complejas que nos
transportan a luchar llorar cantar y
pensar que son tan fuertes que no solo
sostienen un mundo inventado
completamente por el autor sino que
también pueden cambiar la perspectiva de
lector del mundo real y que solo regresa
Cuando llegamos a la última página no
estoy segura si alguien tiene la
respuesta a esta pregunta más aún todos
los días se crean mundos ficticios en
nuestras Mentes computadoras hasta en la
servilletas del restaurante de la otra
calle la verdad es que la imaginación y
un deseo figurativamente de vivir en tu
propio mundo es todo lo que necesitas
para comenzar a escribir una novela no
Sonia hogwarts o la cantina en la guerra
de las Galaxias pero he escrito algunas
novelas de misterio científico para
niños y adolescentes he aquí algunas
preguntas y métodos que usado para
ayudarme a crear los mundos en donde se
desarrollan la trama de esos libros
comienzo con un lugar básico y una época
ya sea un mundo de fantasía o en un
contexto futurista del mundo real Es
importante saber dónde estás y si estás
trabajando en el pasado presente o
futuro me gusta crear una línea de
tiempo que muestre como el mundo llegó a
formarse qué eventos del pasado ayudaron
a darle la forma que tiene hoy luego uso
una lluvia de ideas para responder a
estas preguntas que generan los detalles
de mi mundo ficticio qué leyes existen
en este lugar lo cubre todo desde las
leyes de la gravedad o su inexistencia
hasta las leyes sociales y el castigo
para los que las violan
Qué tipo de gobierno Existe en este
mundo Quién tiene poder y quién no En
qué cree La gente y qué es lo que esta
sociedad valora más luego hay que pensar
sobre la vida cotidiana Cómo es el clima
en este mundo Dónde viven sus habitantes
o trabajan o van a la escuela que comen
y Cómo juegan Cómo Trata a sus niños y
ancianos Cómo se relacionan con plantas
y animales de ese mundo y cómo son las
plantas y los animales
Qué tipo de tecnología hay medios de
transporte tipos de comunicación acceso
a la información hay tantas cosas en las
que pensar Así que pasa un tiempo
pensando en estas cosas y las respuestas
a esas preguntas y andarás por buen
camino en la creación de tu propio mundo
de ficción una vez que conoces tu mundo
como esperas que tus lectores también
Deja que tus personajes ronden
libremente y mira a ver qué pasa
Y pregúntate cómo este mundo que creaste
le da forma a los individuos que habitan
en él Y qué tipo de conflictos puede
surgir responde a estas preguntas y allí
tienes tu historia buena suerte futuro
creador de mundos
maestros lleven a sus escuelas los
materiales gratuitos de las charlas para
estudiantes de Ted y denles a sus
estudiantes la oportunidad de expresar
sus pasiones a través del arte de la
narración de historias obtenga más
información y comience en Ed punto
ted.com/inc español barra inclinada
materiales